[Musica]
[Applauso]
dall'inizio del gennaio del 2001 lavoro
come genetista e all'università di
modena e reggio emilia e in questi 18
anni ho avuto modo di video e quella che
probabilmente è una delle fasi più
emozionanti della storia della genetica
e molto probabilmente anche dell'intera
storia della scienza della vita perché
nel corso di questi ultimi venti anni
abbiamo imparato a leggere con una
enorme facilità tutti quei tutte quelle
informazioni che sono scritte dentro il
dna di qualsiasi organismo sia un mero
che è un microrganismo una pianta un
animale siamo in grado di leggere tutte
le informazioni che ci sono nel dna e di
aggiungere informazioni questo viaggio
comincia nel 2001 comincia nel 2001 con
il sequenziamento del progetto genoma
umano cioè nel 2001 per la prima volta
riusciamo ad avere informazioni su tutti
è quello che le nostre cellule possono
fare perché lo possono fare tutti i
nostri geni a questo punto hanno una
sequenza ne possiamo dire che cosa fanno
chiudere il progetto genoma è stato
considerato una sfida estremamente
importante da un punto di vista
culturale da un punto di vista
tecnologico perché per complessità
secondo e quindi soliti della scienza
sequenziare il progetto genere umano era
secondo in classifica ideale solo dopo
le missioni apollo che hanno portato
l'uomo sulla luna un progetto complicato
perché perché è un progetto che è
costato 3 miliardi di dollari ha visto
lavorare assieme più di mille
ricercatori provenienti un po da tutto
il mondo ed è un progetto che è durato
soli 13 anni sistemavano i due assi 15
in realtà in soli 13 anni sono riusciti
ad avere che cosa la sequenza completa
dei nostri geni e è una stata una
scoperta importantissima ancora oggi il
genoma umano viene considerato il
patrimonio dell'umanità e aveva il
progetto genoma umano ha chiaramente
creato tante aspettative perché perché
questo punto potremmo chiederci ciascuno
di noi che cosa nel proprio dna
posso leggere nel vostro genoma il
vostro destino quali malati avrete quali
alimenti o farmaci potete usare o quali
e dovete evitare e questo è quello che
hanno cominciato a chiedersi anche i
genetisti e chiaro che se le dicessi
devo fare un nuovo progetto genoma mi
servono altri tredici anni e fai
miliardi di dollari
immagino che non sarete immediatamente
disponibili a fare una donazione alla
fine di questa conferenza
che cosa è successo che i genetisti
hanno cominciato a dire se noi avessimo
la capacità di sequenziale dna in modo
veloce economico e successivo potremmo
dire a ciascuna persona che cosa nel
proprio dna e quindi cosa è stato
richiesto
speriamo ci sia un'evoluzione
scientifica un'evoluzione tecnologica e
questo è esattamente quello che c'è
stato quello che è successo nel corso in
particolare degli ultimi dieci anni e
che le metodiche di sequenziamento sono
diventate sempre più veloci sono
diventate sempre più processi ve sono
diventate sempre più economiche che cosa
vuole dire dieci anni fa io avevo in
grado di sequenziare un tratto di dna
nel mio laboratorio impiegando circa due
ore per sequenziare 1000 nucleotidi cioè
per capire in che ordine erano i
nucleotidi che sono le lettere i
componenti di base del dna quindi due
ore mille nucleotidi spendendo circa 10
dollari 10 euro
oggi che cosa posso fare nel mio
laboratorio in un paio di ore posso
sequenziare una giga base di dna c'è un
miliardo di nucleotidi e se io dicessi
voglio sequenziare il genoma il mio
genoma oggi lo potrei fare con meno di
mille euro quindi l'evoluzione
tecnologica è stata enorme
e questo ha avuto tante conseguenze
perché da che a questo punto ciascuno di
voi potrebbe farsi il proprio genoma è
chiaro che è un esperimento un po
costosetto però potreste andare a vedere
che cosa c'è nel vostro genoma e non
solo perche a questo punto fra il
progetto genoma che cosa ha significato
sviluppare strumenti estremamente veloci
ed efficaci per sequenziare dna ha
voluto dire sviluppare delle banche dati
in cui accumulare tutte questi dati
perché se i dati sono se progetto gene
umano è un patrimonio dell'umanità tutti
questi dati devono essere pubblici in
più questi dati io li devo poteva
analizzare e quindi c'è stato uno
sviluppo informatico è nata la
bioinformatica
a questo punto però che cosa è successo
che chi come me lavora con insetti e
combattere di interesse reali o ha avuto
la possibilità di poter fare il genoma
dell'animale della pianta del mio
collega nismo con cui lavora
che cosa significa che il progetto gene
umana è stato il volano per una vera e
propria rivoluzione che ha avuto un
effetto su chiunque lavori con qualsiasi
organismo quelli che avete visto adesso
compariva sono quelli che io chiamo i
genomi da copertina ci sono i genomi
delle specie più note però a questo
punto l'idea è poi potete prendere
qualsiasi organismo e avere il suo
genoma
io ho lavorato ultimamente con un
batterio di cui non si sapeva niente mi
hanno dato un batterio e mi hanno detto
ma questo batterio cosa fa e che laddove
non è che potete guardare lo e dire che
cosa fa abbiamo questo suo dna
due settimane dopo avevamo il suo
progetto genoma completamente
sequenziato sappiamo esattamente che
cosa fa quel batterio senza aver fatto
nessun esperimento questo lo potete fare
con le piante e lo potete fare con un
animale e non potete fare quindi per
affrontare qualsiasi tematica sia per
voi interessante una delle applicazioni
che io trovo più interessanti che
possiamo di sviluppare e affrontare lo
studio della domesticazione la
domesticazione è quella quel processo
fantastico per cui i nostri antenati
sono riusciti a domestic aree quindi
passare da piante selvatiche a varietà
domestica te la domesticazione quel
processo meraviglioso per cui i nostri
antenati sono passati dal teosinte che è
quella piccola spighetta che vedete
sulla sinistra ai mais moderni la
domesticazione quindi è un processo
incredibile perché studiando la
domesticazione noi possiamo studiare la
storia della nostra civiltà e è chiaro
che già solo questa prima immagine di
spiega la potenza della domesticazione
se vi dicessi vi invito a cena e vi
offre una bella spiga di teo sinte e
potete anche fare il bis e non sono
convinto che molti di voi tornerebbero a
cena a casa mia
al contrario si aprisse una bella
pannocchia di mais è questo che passò
questo processo lo posso studiare oggi a
livello genetico possiamo avere il
genoma della specie selvatica possiamo
avere il genoma delle varietà oggi
coltivate possiamo andare a vedere che
cosa è accaduto
questo diventa ancora più evidente se
andiamo a prendere questa piantina
questo assicurerà cioè una piantina
abbastanza insignificante ha detto
villini giallini molto carini però da
questa pianta insignificante
la domesticazione ha portato alla
comparsa del cavolo del broccolo del
cavolfiore cioè quando voi mangiate il
cavolo broccolo un cavolfiore state
mangiando un mutante
non spaventatevi non è nulla di
pericoloso state mangiando una pianta
che ha avuto una mutazione per cui da
quella piantina che vedete al 100 sono
le private le varietà addomesticate come
hanno fatto ottenere questo risultato i
nostri antenati non lo sappiamo
stiamo parlando di qualcosa che è
successo 10 12.000 anni fa studiare il
genio ma ci permette di capire che cosa
hanno fatto i nostri antenati questo
diventa importante perché perché quando
i nostri antenati hanno fatto la
domesticazione ovviamente non
conoscevano la genetica non avevano
strumenti molecolari per vedere che cosa
stavano facendo e quindi hanno ottenuto
solo alcune delle possibili potenziali
forme domestic atika una pianta
selvatica ci poteva dare e quindi cosa
possiamo fare oggi prendiamo tutte
queste varietà possiamo avere il loro
genoma e possiamo andare a vedere quali
sono le mutazioni che sono alla base di
quelle caratteristiche per cui questa è
la vita ci piacciono ma una volta che
abbiamo questo dato possiamo fare una
cosa bellissima
possiamo pensare di ripetere la
domesticazione cioè possiamo pensare di
ripartire dalle piante selvatiche henri
domestica e le per creare qualcosa che
rispetti le necessità attuali fosse di
domesticazione abbiamo detto avvenuto
tra i 10 12 mila anni fa quando il clima
sulla terra era ben diversa da quella
attuale sia per il regime di temperatura
che per piovosita quindi le piante che
noi abbiamo adesso non sono quelle
varietà che probabilmente saranno molto
produttive nel prossimo futuro
perché quindi non ripetere la
domesticazione chi di voi si interessa
di bile già evoluzionistica conoscerà
sicuramente sì wengè i gold un gigante
dell'evoluzione se di jay gould ci dice
guardate che se voi prendete il film
della storia della vita l'ho rimandato
indietro le riavvolgete lo fate
ripartire non otterrete mai due volte lo
stesso risultato perché l'evoluzione si
basa su mutazioni casuali
questo è verissimo ma se noi lavoriamo
quella selezione naturale
noi oggi in genetica possiamo lavorare
con la selezione artificiale possiamo
essere noi che generazione dopo
generazione
in laboratorio controlliamo quello che
si sta formando non vi sto dicendo
andiamo in un campo e aspettiamo che
compaiono le mutazioni per dare qualcosa
che ci interessa sappiamo quali sono le
mutazioni che diamo e dobbiamo avere
siamo noi che andiamo a mettere la dove
vogliamo avere la per produrre quello
che ci serve per garantire le produzioni
alimentari nel prossimo futuro
e a questo punto possiamo essere noi a
decidere
che caratteristiche queste piante devono
avere poi capite che cominciamo a
cambiare un po il modo in cui vediamo i
viventi che ci circondano
perché a questo punto possiamo pensare
di influenzare la forma dei viventi ma
aggiungiamo un altro elemento
noi abbiamo a disposizione un enorme
patrimonio di piante che vengono
identificate come semi domestic a te
sono piante per cui ha cominciato il
processo di una masticazione
ma poi per cause contingenti questo
processo non si è completato ma noi
sappiamo quali sono le caratteristiche
che li pianti addomesticate devono avere
ad esempio tutte le volte che voi
prendete una pianta per seme che cosa
insieme è diventato grande il seme
animano in una spiga il semi germinano
simultaneamente hanno una demenza
ridotta la pianta che porta alla spiga
rimane a retta e non si sdraia tutte
queste sono caratteristiche fenotipiche
direbbe un genetista
cioè caratteristiche voi potete
osservare ma di cui noi conosciamo i
geni e la cosa che si è osservato anche
anche se le piante domestica te sono
molto diverse l'una dall'altra in tenda
punto di vista tassonomico molto spesso
i geni che sono coinvolti sono gli
stessi e quindi che cosa succede che noi
oggi possiamo prendere una pianta
addomesticata e vedeva che geniale
possiamo prendere una pianta semi
domestic ata e completare nella
domesticazione e questo portasse in baia
di fantascientifico ma in realtà è
quello che è stato fatto con la patata o
meglio con due cugine della patata sono
due piante che pertengono allo stesso
genere ma non sono della specie della
stessa specie che vantaggio c'è ogni
pianta si ammala perché viene a contatto
con patogeni parassiti piante di specie
diverse non sono ugualmente sensibili
agli stessi patogeni alcuni gruppi di
ricerca hanno preso due specie che sono
simili alla patata hanno ottenuto un
tubero che analogo a quello della patata
ma essendo derivato da un'altra specie
non ama la delle stesse malattie e
quindi questo diventa interessante
perché volevi e che voi partite da una
specie se mi domestica temi completate
il processo di domesticazione come avete
scelto voi in laboratorio noi finora
abbiamo sempre guardato alla genetica
come una disciplina storica cioè
leggevamo nel dna la storia evolutiva di
quella specie noi questo lo possiamo
ancora fare ma se prima igienici
servivano per studiare le forme della
natura
noi oggi possiamo definire il
laboratorio che forma dove avere la
natura nel prossimo futuro
quindi non solo i geni per la forma ma
definire noi le forme
se prima eravamo passeggeri
dell'evoluzione e vedevamo dove
l'evoluzione ci aveva portato dove ha
portato i nostri antenati e le piante e
gli animali che vivono con noi a questo
punto possiamo essere noi coloro che
guidano l'evoluzione e questo lo
possiamo fare perché oltre a lavorare
col materiale genetico che c'è già nelle
piante possiamo pensare di aggiungere
informazione genetica
il mio consiglio assegnate di queste
lettere chris per chris è una metodica
estremamente interessante perché grazie
a questo strumento che tra l'altro stato
è derivato dalla ricerca di base perché
è il modo è derivato dal modo in cui i
batteri eliminano i virus che potrebbero
uccidere utilizzando questa metodica voi
potete prendere un gene qualsiasi e
inserirlo nel genoma di un qualsiasi
vivente decidendo dove quel gene deve
andare a collocarsi e quindi potete
aggiungere delle funzioni
potete aggiungere solo un gene no potete
in giungere addirittura intere di
metaboliche tutto questo è possibile
grazie a due brillantissime genetisti si
chiamano jennifer 2 nei ed emanuele
charpentier che per la prima volta hanno
capito che questo sistema
poteva avere delle applicazioni e su chi
su chiunque dna è chiaro che se vi dico
abbiamo un metodo per modificare il
genoma cosa vuole dire che qui voi
potete scegliere un gene aggiungero
oppure potete scendere prendere un gene
che ha una certa sequenza nucleotidica e
dire questa sequenza e la voglio
cambiare
correggere pensate di una persona che ha
una malattia genetica
andate a correggere la mutazione che gli
causa la malattia genetica
quindi immediatamente quando si parla di
cristo viene in mente questo la
possibilità di fare l'editing
dell'umanità
vorrei assicurarvi la maggior parte
degli scienziati non vuole fare esseri
umani geneticamente modificati
ci sono alcuni ricercatori la cui
attività non italiani sfortunatamente la
cui attività andrebbe monitorata proprio
perché invece stanno lavorando per
sull'uomo e noi non siamo pronti né
tecnicamente né da un punto di vista
etico per lavorare con l'uomo è alta la
maggior parte degli scienziati non vuole
fare bambini geneticamente modificati
vuole fare zucchine geneticamente
modificate vuole fare le piante che
possono essere coltivate e che
rispondano alle sfide che oggi
l'agricoltura si trova ad affrontare
perché perché voi immaginate la
globalizzazione oggi è una
globalizzazione non solo delle merci una
globalizzazione dei patogeni è una
globale quello penalizzazione dei
parassiti e quindi gli agricoltori si
trovano a fronteggiare ogni anno una
nuova specie invasiva piovosità e luigi
meli protesista ormai sono imprevedibili
dobbiamo avere qualche cosa per
rispondere e questo qualche cosa sono
delle nuove varietà che non ci sono in
natura e che abbiamo la possibilità di
costruire quindi non immaginate che chi
fa scienza genetico in questo modo
voglia fare un bambino geneticamente
modificato vogliamo fare delle piante
geneticamente migliorate
perché a questo punto potremmo anche
pensare di prendere una pianta selvatica
domestica e la migliorare la e
rispondere a quelle che sono le
necessità attuali
e chiaro che questo evento la di che
hanno delle potenzialità in one di
perché vi dicevo li possiamo applicare a
qualsiasi organismo nel mio laboratorio
ad esempio lavoriamo con batterie
insetti di interesse agrario e li della
quale ad esempio un progetto che abbiamo
è quello di prendere dei batteri e di
modificare geneticamente in modo da
poterli rimini mette o in suoli in cui
la biodiversità microbica è stata
fortemente compromessa e quindi il suolo
è molto antica operato
oppure possiamo pensare di prendere dei
batteri ed è quello che stiamo già
facendo e far sì che questi batteri
producano delle molecole che sono in
grado di stimolare la pianta ad
utilizzare meglio i fertilizzanti e
quindi possiamo usare meno fertilizzanti
possiamo usare molecole che scrivono
alla pianta produrre molecole difensive
e quindi possiamo usare meno chimica in
campo la genetica diventa oggi una delle
armi più potenti che possiamo avere per
vincere la sfida della sostenibilità e o
in dell'agricoltura sempre più
sostenibile e che è genetista americano
che vedete qui in foto e dice che noi
stiamo vivendo quella che si chiama una
fase di regenesi in che senso di
regenesi nel senso che noi possiamo
ripetere l'atto della genesi nel senso
quell atto creativo che è descritto nel
libro della genesi
ora capisco che citare il libro della
genesi parlando di genetica può sembrare
un po blasfemo però ha un grande
genetista e soprattutto anche un
genetista che di cognome fa
possiamo anche concederlo ma quello che
lui mi dice noi abbiamo delle enormi
possibilità tecniche e abbiamo il dovere
di sfruttare le un altro grande
genetista americano che si chiama craig
venter
ricevo le date che oggi il l'unico
limite che la scienza è l'immaginazione
dei ricercatori perché noi oggi abbiamo
tutti gli strumenti per costruire il
futuro dobbiamo solo immaginare che tipo
di futuro vogliamo è chiaro che
associati a tutte queste possibilità
deve essere abbinato il senso di
responsabilità la responsabilità per cui
gli scienziati devono assicurarsi che
quello che fanno non sia pericoloso che
quello che fanno non sia dannoso per gli
altri uomini per gli altri specie
animali e vegetali ma importante
ricordare che responsabilità
vorrei anche dire assicurare perché chi
produce quello che noi mangiamo sia in
grado di rispondere alle sfide che
arrivano oggi preston salina vuole dire
dare il meglio dell'innovazione anche in
campo lavora
tenete conto che molto spesso noi
abbiamo in mente il concetto di
tradizione
in realtà ciò che noi chiamiamo
tradizione i nostri nonni chiamava in
innovazione e la storia della
domesticazione è questo è una storia di
innovazione l'evoluzione del nostro cibo
è passata da verso l'evoluzione
l'evoluzione del nostro cibo passa dallo
studio del suo dna
grazie
[Applauso]